Thanks to the box office success of Jigsaw,
it looks like we'll be getting a ninth Saw
movie in the next couple years.
I think the filmmakers counted on this happening,
because they seem to have left little clues
like this one, to set up the next installment.
Before we get this started, I know what you
people are going to say.
"Oh, Hoffman could still be alive.
Bobby Dagan could be a disciple of Jigsaw!
Blah blah blah!"
And to that, I say...
Hoffman is dead, OK?
He's chained in the same spot that Adam was
in the original Saw.
We all know there's only one way out of that
Gordon clearly throws away the key.
As for the others, I'll do a full rundown
of who I think might be alive and possibly
appearing in Saw IX.
But honestly, I don't see anyone from the
original 7 movies making a return.
I mean, what was the point of Jigsaw if not
to freshen things up and bring the franchise
back to theaters?
We got all new characters, and I don't think
any of the other sequels had a total of zero
flashbacks to other movies.
Even the title, breaking the numeric sequence
of Saw films just tells me that this is supposed
to be a fresh slate in a way.
It wasn't my favorite Saw film by any means,
but I do admire the way it revived the property
without relying on a reboot to wipe away the
glorious continuity that's been established.
And I think it did a great job of laying the
foundations for Saw IX, so that's exactly
where I'll start.
The big question going into the new movie
is who's going to be the next Jigsaw?
In the last movie, we saw Logan Nelson replicating
Jigsaw's teachings.
At first it would appear that Nelson is a
corrupt Jigsaw because he, like Hoffman, uses
the Jigsaw image for personal vendetta and
selfish reasons.
However, in the final moments, Nelson reveals
that everyone he puts into his game deserved
to be there under John Kramer's ideals.
He mentions that the first three people in
his game were criminals that got off the hook
that were similar to the players in Jigsaw's
original game.
Remember, the game we saw in the movie was
John Kramer's game from 10 years ago.
We only actually see little glimpses of Nelson's
game and the victims.
The last two players were Halloran and Nelson.
Halloran deserves to be there because he's
the one who took bribes and got those criminals
off the hook, including the murderer of Nelson's
wife.
And then there's Nelson himself, who switched
the labels on John Kramer's brain scan and
never got punished for it.
He never woke up from John Kramer's sedative
in time to play the game in which he was originally
supposed to be tested.
So he put himself in his own game in order
to test himself and see if he was as talented
as Jigsaw.
This also replicates John putting himself
in the room in the original Saw.
Everything seems to add up towards him being
the perfect successor to Jigsaw.
Some might argue that Nelson can't really
continue being Jigsaw in a future movie, but
I think there's evidence that he can.
Unlike John Kramer, who tends to leave the
corpses in his secret locations, Nelson moves
his to be discovered by the public.
But he doesn't have to do that for Detective
Halloran.
Logan has set things up in a way to make everyone
think that Halloran is the new Jigsaw.
In fact, the only part he seems to care about
from the audio admission is this:
"Innocent people died because of me I did
it!"
So if Halloran were to disappear now, everyone
would think that he is responsible, allowing
Logan to continue the work of Jigsaw with
new games in the future.
But he makes one mistake.
John Kramer tells him to never allow personal
anger and revenge to interfere.
But as far as I can tell, there's one participant
who never gets a fair chance at redemption,
and that is Edgar Munsen, the man who murdered
Nelson's wife.
He seems to be involved in another game setup
by Nelson, and despite appearing to succeed,
Nelson shoots him, takes him off life support
and dumps him in John Kramer's grave.
The original Jigsaw never actually murdered
anyone, but Nelson makes this mistake to avenge
his wife.
He may have faltered off of the path John
Kramer set for him due to the PTSD he picked
up in the army, which you can read about by
pausing here in the movie.
We've already seen what happens when one of
Jigsaw's successors break the rules, the disciples
of Jigsaw come after him to make things right.
Even if it's not mentioned in Saw IX, you
can bet that a showdown between Logan Nelson
and the disciples of Jigsaw is coming in the
future.
So who's going to be part of this battle?
We know Dr. Lawrence Gordon has played this
part in the past, and he's someone who's definitely
still alive and active.
I've speculated on who these other pigmasks
who help Dr. Gordon could be.
Some of you in the comments of a previous
video said that they could be minor characters
from the Saw VII opening based on some producers'
commentary track.
I'm going to go ahead and say that's not canon,
and if that was the intention at one time
it's going to be changed now that they are
continuing the series.
I speculated that Nelson may actually be one
of Gordon's assistants, but there are a couple
of other possibilities as well.
This is where the characters from previous
films could come in.
It would make sense that Gordon would work
with any of the other members of the Jigsaw
survivor group from Saw VII.
But there are other survivors that weren't
seen in that group.
These include Brent and Tara Abbott from Saw
VI.
The father of of that family was the guy who
was denied insurance coverage needed to survive,
so it makes sense that his family would want
to see justice served.
I could see Brent, now a fully grown adult,
being a powerful force in a new movie.
Another character who would be grown up now
is Daniel Matthews, the son of the Detective
from Saw II.
He was also a survivor.
It would be easy to see him learning under
John Kramer's wing after losing his father.
Then we've got Corbett Denlon, a survivor
who lost both of her parents in Saw III.
Because Kramer was already gone, she would
have had to have been trained by the corrupt
Mark Hoffman, meaning that if she does end
up appearing again, she might actually be
more on Nelson's side.
Then there's Pamela Jenkins, the reporter
who sensationalized Jigsaw stories for her
own personal gain.
She'd be another candidate to be on Nelson's
side, because she may have been corrupted
by Hoffman.
By the way, Nelson does have anonymous people
helping him too.
It could be cool in a future movie to see
two Jigsaws and their followers engaged in
a war of ideals.
But like I said before, I think it's unlikely
we'll see the return of old characters, because
the new Jigsaw film sets up the possibility
for new Pig Mask minions as well.
Eleanor is an obvious candidate, due to her
fandom for Jigsaw and the fact that Nelson
is grooming her throughout the movie.
The last we see of her in Jigsaw shows her
getting picked up after escaping the pig farm,
and she's got a look of fear on her face,
so maybe someone from the survivor group has
plans for her.
There's also the fansite she spends all that
time on, Jigsaw Rules, which could offer a
new pool of candidates to be assistants.
Nelson will need the extra help, because there
are plenty more criminals set free during
Halloran regime, and there could be other
corrupt officials as well.
If you're still not convinced there is going
to be another one, let me direct your attention
to the news clippings in Eleanor's studio.
This article from the Saw V era says the story
will be continued on 6, 7, 8 and 9!
If that's not proof enough for you, then look
at this story which is supposedly about Jigsaw,
but the contents of the article seem to only
talk about...
Ticketmaster?
They want us to buy tickets to Jigsaw, so
that they can make Saw IX!
So if you bought tickets to Jigsaw, or if
you're excited about the revival of the franchise,
let me know by leaving a like on this video.
Leave your ideas for the next Saw in the comments,
and if there are enough cool ones, maybe I'll
feature them in a future video.
And if you haven't already, remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.